[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à part
zahia
je vous explique un truc c'est qu'on de
bavois dirty dancing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dgo
à jouer
[Musique]
la troupe de dirty dancing est avec nous
et malheureusement le danseur a eu un
problème au genou ouais on a eu à nous
envoyer un certificat médical et/ou une
thalasso le gars c'est parce qu'il a eu
et on s'est dit ils vont venir un autre
jour mais quand même volé un petit peu
de tortis dancing donc on a demandé au
débotté à deux coupes
jean michel maire et isabelle morini
bosc et kelly et maxime leur faire la
chorégraphie de dirty dancing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma mère
le faire
[Musique]
es tu
allez
c'est d'ailleurs là bas les apporter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle
je veux pas m on est en bas de la voile
au près il y avait le persil qui sortait
du taraf
allez on y va deuxième coupe kelly et
maxime
[Applaudissements]
un gâchis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais
k
ça
m
je
[Applaudissements]
c'est une eau de la république
[Musique]